madame la présidente madame la première
ministre collègues le président a été
élu sans mandat voici venu sa première
ministre sans confiance ce mercredi 6
juillet est une date à marquer d'une
pierre noire pour la démocratie
madame elisabeth bornes vous devenez
officiellement la première ministre d'un
gouvernement minoritaire vous êtes bel
et bien chargé de conduire la politique
de la nation par le seul fait du prince
vous ne devez votre place qu'un
président de la république lui-même élu
par défaut
il faut le dire
l'exercice auquel nous nous prêtons ici
est une mascarade
nous parlerons chacun à la suite avant
que vous ne rende riez tranquillement à
matignon ainsi vous fait l'aveu de votre
faiblesse vous ne vous soumettez pas au
vote de confiance de peur de ne pas
l'obtenir jamais depuis 30 ans une
première ministre mme c'était défilé
ainsi vous avez été battu aux élections
législatives
vous avez perdu 100 des 100 sièges vous
êtes classé dernière chef de
gouvernement d'europe en
représentativité populaire seuls 26 %
des votants et 12 % des inscrits se
réclament de votre parti aux dernières
élections mais vous faites comme si de
rien n'était dans ces circonstances
un vote de confiance s'imposer mais vous
avez choisi la fuite le mercredi 6
juillet restera comme ce jour où deux
nouveaux vous avez piétiné le vote des
français votre stratégie désormais c'est
sauve qui peut et vous êtes prêt à tout
jamais au compromis mais à toutes les
compromissions nous avons vu la semaine
dernière
l'étendue de votre forfait morales et
politiques tous sauf la nouvelle union
populaire était votre credo vous vous
êtes livrés à toutes sortes de combines
et de renvoi d'ascenseur le
rassemblement national s'est retiré de
la course à la présidence de l'assemblée
permettant à madame propre iv d'accéder
à son trône le lendemain des députés
demorand
candice président de l'assemblée vous
vous souvenez vous ne cachez plus tôt la
peste brune que le contrôle fiscal quoi
de plus normal quand vous partagez un
programme libéral au service de
l'oligarchie
alors oui nous déposerons une motion de
défiance
c'est ce qui se produit lorsque
l'exécutif n'écoute que lui même il est
temps de vous apprendre le sens du mot
d'ekobo cratie que vous détestez et que
vous ne tolérez que lorsqu'elle vous est
favorable en 1966 votre prédécesseur
georges pompidou qui s'était soustrait
comme vous au vote de confiance
s'exprimer ainsi la lettre et l'esprit
de la constitution de 1958 volts en
effet que le gouvernement soit
entièrement libre de demander ou non un
vote de confiance et qu'ils
appartiennent de préférence à
l'assemblée de mettre en jeu la
responsabilité ministérielle par la
procédure la plus normale est la mieux
adaptée
je veux dire la motion de censure
alors votre part parole nous conseille
de vous écouter avant de préjugés de
quoi que ce soit nous vous avons écouté
madame la première ministre mais surtout
nous vous avons déjà vu à l'oeuvre vous
n'êtes pas à votre premier méfait vous
avez été l'artisane zélé de la casse du
service public ferroviaire et de la case
de l'assurance chômage qui a permis de
réaliser deux milliards d'euros
d'économies sur le dos des plus pauvres
vous n'avez jamais dévié vous souhaitez
toujours gouvernés contre le peuple sauf
que votre pouvoir est en voie de
décomposition
depuis le 19 juin 2022 vous avez tout
fait pour dissimuler votre pouvoir par
effraction vous avoir vous avez d'abord
lancé une opération de sauvetage le
président de la république a proposé des
alliances texte par tex ou un
gouvernement d'union nationale mais il
ne s'agit surtout pas pour lui d'
infléchir son programme de maltraitance
sociale et d'irresponsabilité écologique
non puisqu'il a reçu dit il une
légitimité clair sur le fondement d'un
projet clair là encore vous refaites
l'histoire emmanuel macron n'a pas été
élu par adhésion à son projet
il a été élu face à l'extrême droite les
citoyens avaient le chantre le pire et
le pire du pire ils ont choisi le pire
malgré tout emmanuel macron ne veut rien
lâcher de son programme impopulaire
dorénavant tout sera comme auparavant
pour lui l'élection législative n'a
jamais eu lieu comme toujours un
maquereau ni l'essentiel est de simuler
la démocratie pour mieux la bafouer le
président afin d'engager les discussions
désormais la balle serait dans le camp
des oppositions il ne nous incombe rey à
nous de nous situer par rapport au parti
majoritaire qui n'est à présent plus
majoritaire en d'autres termes soit nous
avalisons la guerre sociale la retraite
à 65 ans et le conditionnement du rsa au
travail gratuit soit nous sommes une
minorité de blocage soit nous sommes de
votre côté c'est à dire contre le peuple
soit nous sommes pour l'intérêt général
donc pour vous hors du champ républicain
votre ministre de l'intérieur nous
désigne comme des ennemis là encore vous
avez en horaire tout ce qui s'apparente
à une opposition démocratique et fait
vivre l'alternative dans ce pays ce sera
donc vous le déluge dites vous nous
disons que quand c'est vous c'est le
chaos nous savons que pour vous depuis
si longtemps
la terre ne tournait pas autour du
soleil mais autour de jupiter en vérité
la macro ni peine à faire le deuil des
cinq années passées elle traîne une
nostalgie enfantine les playmobil lui
manque qu'il était doux ce temps où 300
députés a ployé de concert sur un bouton
sans prendre le temps de lire les textes
le pouvoir est désormais en disgrâce
impropre à la démocratie alors là
matroni se replie sur elle-même elle
grogne elle boude ses pulsions
d'éviction du show républicains lui
reprenne le sectarisme revient au galop
hors de question de signer la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle de
l'année pèse visant à protéger le droit
à l'avortement le pouvoir minoritaire
fera sa propre proposition même si elle
n'est inscrite nulle part à l'ordre du
jour de cette session peut-être parce
que vous avez préféré mettre ce texte au
placard pour acheter la complaisance du
rassemblement national
il va falloir vous y faire
vous n'êtes plus le centre de gravité
politique
vous êtes battus
après tout pourquoi nous ferions vous
confiance madame ou bornes il faut le
dire vous êtes une rescapée vous êtes la
première ministre la moins bien élu de
la vème république
vous avez maintenu un gouvernement a
troué assure 6 3 devant ministres ont
été défaits aux législatives la ministe
des autres maires a tenu trente six
jours avant de prendre la fuite que dire
du ministre accusé de plusieurs de vos
gueules maintenu en poste jusqu'à lundi
ou de celles visées pour des viols jean
écologique toujours en fonction à ce
jour le camoufler électorale des
législatives porte votre nom mais vous
voilà toujours là un gouvernement
chaotique en succès d'un autre vous
promouvez les amis qu'ils vous restent
rares sont ceux qui veulent monter à
bord du titanic alors l'équipe des
volontaires ressemble à s'y méprendre à
un fonds de tiroir dans ce gouvernement
d'harmoniser on croise des hommes
essentiellement aux ministres contre
cinq femmes en revanche un homme
secrétaire d'état contre neuf femmes
renaissance a par ailleurs réfuté la
manif pour tous le ministère de la
jeunesse et sous la tutelle du ministère
des armées les outre-mers dépendent de
l'intérieur peut-être comme récompense
de l'envoi du gign et du raid en
guadeloupe la planification écologique a
disparu au profit d'un ministère piloté
par un novice votre nouveau monde est
une machine à remonter le temps
pourquoi nous ferions view confiance
avoue qu'ils découvraient les profiteurs
de guerre mais ne fait rien quand ton
talent grange 16 milliards de bénéfices
vous qui présentait des mesures sociales
inférieures au niveau de l'inflation
vous à nouveau épinglée par le haut
conseil pour le climat pour votre
inaction climatique vous qui ne fait
confiance qu'aux riches et aux pollueurs
vous qui n'avez rien fait pour enrayer
la crise des urgences et des
établissements de santé dans le pays
nous ne vous faisons pas confiance mais
en font peu vous chaud madame la
première ministre soyons clairs croyez
vous que notre modèle de production et
de consommation doivent bifurqué pour
lutter contre le dérèglement climatique
nous oui
vous ne croyez vous que le marché les
incantations soit en incapacité de
régler tous les problèmes nous oui vous
ne trouvez vous indigne que 10 millions
de personnes vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté quand cinq milliardaire possède
autant que 27 millions de français nous
oui vous non
que cela vous plaise ou non il va
falloir vous y habituer cela s'appelle
la démocratie
madame la première ministre il faudra
vous soumettre ou vous des maîtres nous
ne croyons pas une seule seconde à une
ma chronique y retrouve la raison vous
avez présenté votre feuille de route
celle du dépôt de bilan de monsieur
emmanuel macron voici la nôtre de
feuille de route cette semaine nous
avons présenté notre deuxième
proposition de loi commune à la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale
smic à 1500 euros nets blocage des prix
à la baisse des produits de première
nécessité et du carburant
revalorisation de 10% des aides au
logement et du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires
garantie d'autonomie à 1063 euros par
mois pour les jeunes
augmentation de l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire des conjugale isation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé gel des
loyers voilà des mesures qui seraient de
nature à débloquer le pays car la
minorité de blocage à la vie digne à la
redistribution des richesses à la
sauvegarde de nos écosystèmes
c'est vous